THIS POINT DONALD TRUMP ISN'T
THE ONE WHO NEEDS TO BE
EXONERATED.
JOHN KERRY, A FORMER CIA OFFICER
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
HE WORKED AT THE CA FOR A LONG
TIME UNDER JOHN BRENNAN WILL
BACK YOUR PROSECUTION WISHED HE
WERE SENT TO PRISON FOR A CRIME
THAT I DON'T THINK WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A CRIME TODAY.
TELL ME WITH THAT PERSPECTIVE
YOUR REACTION TO WATCHING JOHN
BRENNAN TROT IT BEFORE THE
CAMERAS FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HE SAID HE WAS AN EXPERT ON THE
CONSPIRACY.
>> THIS WAS SCANDALOUS FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT OF WHICH WAS
THAT JOHN BRENNAN HAS REPEATEDLY
USED THE WORD TREASON, THE WORD
TRADER DESCRIBING THE PRESIDENT.
TREASON IS A DEATH PENALTY
CHARGE.
AS HE SERIOUSLY SAYING OR HAS HE
BEEN SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT
OUGHT TO BE EXECUTED FOR
SOMETHING HAVING TO DO WITH A
SCANDAL THAT NEVER EXISTED?
TO ME HE IS NOT A SERIOUS
PERSON.
HE SHOULDN'T BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY
BY US OR BY ANYONE ELSE.
I WILL GET PERSONAL.
I WORKED WITH HIM FOR MANY YEARS
AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT HE WAS
AN OVER HIS HEAD INTELLECTUALLY
AND I THINK IS PROVEN THAT
REPEATEDLY IN HIS RESPONSE AS
THE REACTION TO THE NEWS COMING
OUT.
>> Tucker: THAT IS FUNNY YOU
SAID THAT.
THE DEFAULT ASSUMPTION IS THAT
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CIA IS A
VERY SMART MAN.
THAT IS A COMPLEX JOB.
I WATCHED HIM CLOSELY OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND I'VE
CONCLUDED THAT HE IS NOT VERY
BRIGHT.
I'M NOT ATTACKING HIM.
IT IS CLEARLY THE CASE.
HOW DOES A GUY LIKE THAT RUN THE
CIA?
>> YOU GET THAT JOB BY LATCHING
ONTO GEORGE TENET BEFORE HE EVEN
ENTERED THE CIA.
JOHN BRENNAN IT IN THE 1990s
WAS AS BRIEF OR ONE GEORGE WAS
AT THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
AS A DIRECTOR OF INTELLIGENCE
PROGRAMS.
WHEN HE BECAME A DEPUTY, HE TOOK
JOHN OVER WITH HIM AND THEN JUST
PROMOTED HIM THROUGH THE RANKS
UNTIL HE WAS PRACTICALLY CABINET
LEVEL.
>> Tucker: SUCH AS PEER
CRONYISM?
>> HE WAS ON A ROCKET RIDE TO
THE TOP TO HIS CAREER.
>> Tucker: THE RESULTS OF ALL
THE STUFF THAT WE HAVE WATCHED
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS IS THAT
THE ORDINARY PERSON COME
EVERYONE ELSE KNOWS THAT THESE
AGENCIES ARE RUN BY PEOPLE WHO
WERE MUCH LESS IMPRESSIVE THAN
WE THOUGHT WITH POLITICAL
AGENDAS AND IN SOME CASES THEY
ARE RUTHLESS AND CRUEL.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
FELT THE STING OF THAT AND WENT
TO PRISON.
>> I DID THINGS TO JOHN BRENNAN.
>> Tucker: GUYS LIKE ROGER
STONE ARE HEADED TO PRESENT
BECAUSE OF THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE ARE THE PARDONS RIGHT HERE?
IS IT TIME FOR THE BRANCH TO
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT WE
WILL STOP THE DESTRUCTION OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE DIE COMPLETELY
OUT OF CONTROL BUREAUCRATS.
>> I THINK IT IS THE TIME.
I HEARD LINDSEY GRAHAM SAY THAT
PARDONS WOULD NOT BE MET VERY
WELL RIGHT NOW AND UNITED STATES
SENATE AND I THINK HE IS WRONG.
I THINK OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ROBBED.
LOOK AT MIKE FLYNN AND WITH THAT
POOR GUY HAS GONE THROUGH.
LOOK AT ROGER STONE.
THESE ARE ALL PROCESSED AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS.
THESE ARE FELONIES THAT DIDN'T
EXIST UNTIL THESE PEOPLE WERE
THROWN INTO THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY ARE CRIMES THAT WOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN COMMITTED OTHERWISE.
SINCE INVESTIGATION HAS COME TO
NOT, IT IS TIME TO WIPE THE
SLATE CLEAN.
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE NOT TO PARDON PEOPLE.
THIS IS A SCAM AND A HOAX AND
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE ARE